this but that's just me so so if we flip
this conversation and insert it as a
race yeah you would you'd think that's
fine i don't necessarily think it's a
bad thing but okay
this is spicy i like it interesting i
think one can be racist
and or sexist and not be both
so i think it's possible to understand
the dangers of a male versus female and
not be racist
i also think that some people could say
do you mean sexist or sorry sorry um so
i also think that some people could be
worried about other races having
relations with their women like as often
as the argument that gets put out there
because of their build because of their
physique whatever
and
maybe there's a point to that i mean
there's
people from asia tend to be smaller and
billed people from scandinavia tend to
be tolerant build if you've got a
scandinavian dude walking around asia
yeah most of the guys over there are
going to be a little worried
what do you think
yeah that's why like when you ask the
question i i said it's down to biology
for the male and the female with the
race one i just personally can't see it
down to biology it could hypothetically
be because you could say one one group
is taller and more like and stronger
where one is weaker and smaller
it's like asian yeah yeah black men
and obviously in certain parts of
america the i'm guessing this that show
that um black men are incarcerated more
for violent crimes and agentmen but
their violent crimes are against other
black men they're not they're not
against like but that's not quite
the point but we're not talking about
who said it
no the point so i'm saying like like i'm
not i'm it could be a black person that
says that too she's talking about like
like anybody like overarching like
saying like oh
i saw a black person rob a corner store
all black people rob corner story the
same way we're kind of doing that with
men so it doesn't matter who the crime
is against like the point is when
there's statistical differences is it
okay to make an assumption about a group
and so when you said yes when it was for
men but when we changed it to race you
said no
and so i'm at why yeah i think like if
the if the statistic is you have to
analyze the statistic like very
carefully and like with the whole
situation in america like with the black
on black crime that's it's it's more
within their own race so someone else
who is outside of that race saying oh
but
but you keep you keep moving it yeah
because he could say the same thing yeah
yeah yeah i don't if it's you within
your own race um then yeah that makes
sense what's the difference between me
saying in him saying if the stat still
shows the same thing because it doesn't
show the same thing
that the the stats is showing the crime
is within their own race but we're not
we're not talking about
crime within
a community within we're talking about
what is the difference between
saying you should be afraid of men
because eighty percent of men are scary
and saying okay
eighty percent of black people rob
corner stores eighty percent of white
people
rob a
another type of store
should you categorize like okay i'm not
going to go to a corner store because i
know that black people rob those i'm not
going to go to this type of store
because i know white people are off
those x y z and not saying like the
crime within the community is
it's we're talking about over like
clumping people because we know that
these group of people do that and saying
like is it the same because you're
basically saying well it's like the same
race that owns the store so but that
like that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the the difference
in the crime stat
i guess it's the difference between
sexism and racism yeah right
but it's just it's just interesting how
like one like it we can almost openly
say one and nobody bats an eye but if we
flipped it with race everyone would i
think everyone would admit to it really
if if nobody's looking if the cameras
aren't on and we're talking with just
just our people we say stuff like that
all the time to each other but we just
won't admit it in public i think so
that's the thing that like if someone is
afraid if someone had like a trauma
say i had a trauma like say i guess you
used to get bitten up by black people
all the time and i have a trauma and
every time i see a black person i'm
afraid would you blame me for it
i'm not saying
it's not
but women can openly do that yeah and
and i think if it was reversed like no i
think people would call you yeah they
would call you a racist
but women openly i all the time like
this is oh god all the time when i'm
interviewing people on the streets
they'll say well i like women always
have a horror story that they bring up
like to the point i i it just doesn't
seem credible because everyone has one
yeah but they can openly do that and
it's socially acceptable it's like when
um again with the whale attack
when the lady was saying it's not all
men it's not women but i don't know
where it is so it is all men right no
thomas
she's not all men
right she said no oh man oh man she yes
so she initially she was saying it's not
as in she was copying what um uh paul
said essentially not all men not all men
but i don't know if it is if he's you
know he doesn't wear a shirt says he's
not going to grate me so it is because
of that yeah like what if we switched
yeah exactly and i i remember i was
trying to ask the question that you know
there's throughout history there was
stuff that white women did to black men
and so is it okay for me to then carry
on go through life and saying oh all
white women do this
and the point i was trying to make her
was that just because it's happened
before doesn't mean i can assume that
she's going to do it to me too but we
didn't get to that because you got angry
but yeah the thing is you can't really
blame someone with trauma i understand
it might be racist you can be aware of
it you can go to therapy and whatever
but in the end you can't
blame them for it okay for example when
i was living in greece when i was young
i was dressing up and all that with
makeup and all that
i i had like a lot of albanians beating
the crap out of me and for a very long
time i just i was
yeah i was very
aware
every time i would meet some albanian
guy because i would think okay he's
going to beat me up because he's from
that same
country
don't get wrong i think i think it does
make sense for you to have that feeling
but what i'm saying the point which i
guess paul is trying to make is that you
know
we
people wouldn't openly say that or
openly say that they tend to
discriminate or have a certain idea of
races um based on things that have
happened or based on statistics but yeah
a woman can come here and say menotrash
menindees men at that and
it's seen as oh well she's experienced
it and so it's fine yeah why do you
think it's okay for women to be sexist
but not racist
well it's not just women like the
question
it's more like how women can be sexist
and black and black people can be racist
in in it's i think that's a better
equivalent what do you say
so i think it's a better equivalence is
like how women can be
allowed to be sexist the same way black
people allow to be racist are they
yeah
that's another conversation no no that
cause that's a different conversation
no the question is why is it okay for
women to be sexist and not racist
because
it's it's just
common right it's so it's so like
misandry is so common i hear it every
day but nobody bats an eye
but if but if we switched it to race
they would so is it sexist then the
example you gave of
basically telling a woman you know a man
is different from you you should have
some level of genuine fear like you
can't just walk into a man's house that
you don't know off nowhere and think
he's just another girl you can't treat a
man like a woman right but i'm saying
you shouldn't walk into anyone's